les tireurs d'élite ont profité d'un
moment d'assouplissement du ravisseur
pour pénétrer dans la classe précis de
ce que les spécialistes appellent une
opération de neutralisation avec
christophe thorin dès 5h30 ce matin les
hommes du raid ont reçu l'ordre
d'intervenir
charles pasqua a donné son accord reste
à trouver le moment propice attendre que
le preneur d'otages fatigué relâchons
attention des moyens visuels et sonores
introduit dans la classe leur fournit
cette certitude il est 7 heures 25
en un éclair de policiers du raid
pénètre dans la classe s'approche à
moins de trois mètres de l'homme qui se
réveille
immédiatement il tire trois balles
blindé de 9 mm
trois balles dans la tête de l'autre
côté de la pièce le médecin pédiatre des
pompiers prévenus l'intervention a placé
les six enfants sous les matelas pour
jouer leur dit elle à la tortue en fait
il s'agit de les protéger au cas où tout
explose au moment le preneur d'otages
est abattu une dizaine de policiers du
raid jaïs prennent chacun dans leurs
bras un enfant pour le protéger et
l'emmener au loin c'est la raison pour
laquelle on peut les voir sortir de
l'enceinte de l'école un enfant dans
chaque bras toujours l'apport de
l'explosion
l'opération en tout dans la salle de
classe n'aura pas duré plus de cinq
secondes le preneur de d
5h30 ce matin les hommes du raid ont
reçu l'ordre d'intervenir
charles pasqua a donné son accord reste
à trouver le moment propice attendre que
le preneur d'otages fatigué relâchons
attention des moyens visuels et sonores
introduit dans la classe leur fournit
cette certitude il est 7 heures 25
en un éclair des policiers du raid
pénètre dans la classe s'approche à
moins de trois mètres de l'homme qui se
réveille
immédiatement il tire trois balles
blindé de 9 mm trois balles dans la tête
de l'autre côté de la pièce le médecin
pédiatre des pompiers prévenus
l'intervention a placé les six enfants
sous les matelas pour jouer leur dit
elle à la tortue en fait il s'agit de
les protéger au cas où tout explose au
moment le preneur d'otages est abattu
une dizaine de policiers du raid jaïs
prennent chacun dans leurs bras un
enfant pour le protéger et l'emmener au
loin celle à laquelle on peut les voir
c'est près de l'enceinte de l'école un
enfant mon chemin toujours l'apport de
l'explosion l'opération atout dans la
salle de classe n'aura pas duré plus de
cinq secondes